okay but buddy but what trained chat gpt uh that the compute the train nvidia gpu yeah but that that doesn't affect the answers i'm telling you that that large language model it almost certainly knows how it was trained do you know the address i i can't get the address right now because connor and i in the middle of recording recording. Welcome to ADSP the podcast episode 166 recorded on January 24, 2024. My name is Connor and today I quiz my co-host Bryce about what the top 20 GPU SDKs, libraries, and tools are. Yeah, yeah, he said that she must be a very, very smart dog. Yep. Oh, I have some bad news. My little thing that my microphones go in.
好吧，伙计，但是到底是什么训练了ChatGPT呢？是训练用的计算资源，NVIDIA GPU吗？是的，但这并不影响答案。我告诉你，那个大语言模型几乎肯定知道它是如何被训练出来的。你知道地址吗？我现在拿不到地址，因为康纳和我正在录音。欢迎收听ADSP播客第166期，录制于2024年1月24日。我是康纳，今天我考考我的联合主持人布莱斯，看看排名前20的GPU SDK、库和工具有哪些。是的，是的，他说那一定是一只非常、非常聪明的狗。是的。哦，我有个坏消息。我放麦克风的小东西。
Look at this. Come on, Rode. What's this quality control? This is starting to fall apart. It's not acceptable. Yeah. Oh, I want to... Speaking of quality control, speaking of quality control speaking of quality
看看这个。拜托，Rode。这是什么质量控制？这东西开始散架了。这让人无法接受。是的。哦，我想……说到质量控制，说到质量控制，说到质量
control this is potentially relevant content for the episode so you know about how that that door the door plug fell like off off of that uh that alaska airlines flight like a couple weeks ago. Oh, yeah, I heard about that. Yeah. So there are some reports out now that indicate what the root of the problem was. And the root of the problem seems to be that the four bolts that were supposed to hold the door in place were just not installed at all. And because I'm very tuned into the aviation world, I've been reading some things about this. And the process failure that led to this issue is actually kind of
控制，这可能与本期节目相关。你知道几周前阿拉斯加航空那次航班上的舱门塞掉落的事吗？哦，是的，我听说过。是的。所以现在有一些报告指出问题的根源是什么。问题的根源似乎是本应固定舱门的四个螺栓根本就没有安装。因为我非常关注航空领域，我一直在读一些关于这件事的内容。导致这个问题的流程故障其实有点
interesting. So they thought that there was something defective with the door plug, because there are a lot of issues from the people who provided the door plug. And so when they were doing their QA on the plane before they shipped it out of the factory, they noted that, hey, we got to investigate this door plug. We think the door plug's a problem. So they made a note in the record to go check the door plug. And then they went and checked the door plug. And there's a note on the record that said, all right, we've taken the door out and we've investigated it. And now we're deciding whether or not we're going to replace the door or not. And then the note says, and if we do replace the door with a new one, if we get rid of this one and put in a new one, we will put a note in the system for the door to be rechecked, to do QA on the new door again.
有趣。他们以为舱门塞有什么缺陷，因为提供舱门塞的人有很多问题。所以当他们在飞机出厂前进行质量保证（QA）时，他们注意到，嘿，我们得调查一下这个舱门塞。我们认为舱门塞有问题。于是他们在记录中做了一个备注，要去检查舱门塞。然后他们去检查了舱门塞。记录上有一个备注写着，好了，我们已经把舱门拆下来并调查过了。现在我们正在决定是否要更换这个舱门。然后备注里写着，如果我们确实用一个新的更换了舱门，如果我们处理掉这个旧的换上新的，我们会在系统中做一个备注，要求对舱门进行复检，对新舱门再次进行质量保证。
And see, that's where the mistake was, because they had already taken the door off of the plane. And so because they'd taken the door off of the plane, they needed to redo the QA anyways, regardless of whether they replaced the door. They needed to check that the door was properly reinstalled. But they didn't end up replacing the door. And because they didn't end up replacing the door, they didn't mark that the door needed to be rechecked by QA. And because of that, the door wasn't rechecked by QA and the plane shipped out of the factory without any bolts to hold the door in place. And, you know, my partner being a process engineer, I have now some interest in the field of process and quality control and what leads to the root cause of failures. And I just thought this was quite interesting. You know, I'd say that our listeners don't find it interesting but you know we've we've
你看，错误就在这里，因为他们已经把舱门从飞机上拆下来了。正因为他们把舱门拆下来了，无论是否更换舱门，他们都需要重新进行质量保证。他们需要检查舱门是否正确重新安装。但他们最终没有更换舱门。因为他们没有更换舱门，他们就没有标记舱门需要由质量保证部门复检。正因为如此，舱门没有经过质量保证部门的复检，飞机就在没有任何螺栓固定舱门的情况下出厂了。你知道，我的伴侣是流程工程师，我现在对流程和质量控制领域以及导致故障的根本原因产生了一些兴趣。我只是觉得这很有趣。你知道，我会说我们的听众可能觉得没意思，但你知道我们
recently learned that i don't have my finger on the pulse of what our listeners do and do not find interesting well yeah hopefully my planes that i get on don't have a door taken off and then put back on if it gets taken off let's hope it it gets replaced. Well, I mean, no, I think there's some deep lesson to learn here. Like, you know, if you fix some problem or if you decide there wasn't a problem at all, like if you fix some problem in your code, you need to do something to test that the fix is good and you also need to add some sort of regression test
最近了解到，我并不了解我们的听众觉得什么有趣，什么没趣。好吧，是的，希望我乘坐的飞机不会出现舱门被拆下又装回去的情况，如果被拆下来了，希望它能被更换。嗯，我是说，不，我认为这里有一个深刻的教训。比如，你知道，如果你修复了某个问题，或者如果你决定根本没有问题，比如如果你修复了代码中的某个问题，你需要做些什么来测试修复是否有效，而且你还需要添加某种回归测试
to make sure that you don't run into the problem again i i could imagine ways in which there is a lesson from this that could be learned uh by the software industry yeah don't work on planes all right here's my episode topic for the day. We were recently chatting. Was it a week ago? Was it pre or post a recording? I can't remember. About the landscape of SDKs, libraries, languages that are used to target GPUs. Specifically, in our case, we care about NVIDIA GPUs. And I showed you some diagram that listed
来确保你不会再次遇到这个问题。我可以想象出软件行业可以从中吸取教训的方法。是的，别在飞机上工作。好了，这是我今天的话题。我们最近在聊天。是一周前吗？是在录音前还是录音后？我不记得了。关于用于定位GPU的SDK、库、语言的格局。具体来说，在我们的案例中，我们关心的是NVIDIA GPU。我给你看了一些图表，列出了
off a few of these things and i think it was just today i decided to ask chat gpt to be specific chat gpt 4 which i signed up for in the last couple weeks for a specific task which it was not able to complete successfully but now i paid for it a month. So we may or may not keep it. And the question that I asked was, so now we're going to do a little family feud, this little quiz time. But I think if you can get five out of the top 20 answers that ChatGPT gave, I'll be impressed. And don't worry. I think you're going to do well. But, you know.
其中一些东西，我想就在今天，我决定问问ChatGPT，具体来说是ChatGPT 4，我在过去几周为了一个特定任务订阅了它，但它没能成功完成，不过现在我已经付了一个月的钱。所以我们可能会也可能不会保留它。我问的问题是，现在我们要玩个小游戏，这个小测验时间。但我认为如果你能答对ChatGPT给出的前20个答案中的5个，我会印象深刻。别担心。我觉得你会做得很好。但是，你知道。
Wait, wait, wait. Hang on, hang on. I just need to wait long enough to log into chat gpt don't be honest be honest bryce i can see i can see the light changing on your face i know you're navigating to different websites do not i want to see your hands above your head for the for the next five minutes you can rest them on your head if you want. So the question I asked was, hey, hey. Hang on. I got to get back to seeing your beautiful face.
等等，等等，等等。稍等，稍等。我只需要等足够长的时间登录ChatGPT。别诚实，布莱斯，要诚实。我能看到，我能看到你脸上的光在变化。我知道你在浏览不同的网站。不要，我希望在接下来的五分钟里看到你的双手举过头顶，如果你想的话，可以放在头上。所以我问的问题是，嘿，嘿。稍等。我得回到看着你那张漂亮的脸。
I want hands above your head for the next five minutes while we play this little game. And a listener. You can play along as well. And then after we're done this little top, you know, trying to get five out of 20, I'm curious to see how many. Okay, Google. Open Chat GPT. see how many okay google open chat gpt this question comes in two parts because my first question chat gpt4 when it's going on ad nauseum and detail and i was like i had to correct it anyway so and i'll give you the beginning of chat gpt's answer which is before the list starts so
我希望在接下来的五分钟里，当我们玩这个小游戏时，你的双手举过头顶。听众朋友们，你们也可以一起玩。然后当我们完成这个前20名的小尝试后，我很想看看有多少。好的，谷歌。打开ChatGPT。看看有多少，好的谷歌，打开ChatGPT。这个问题分为两部分，因为我的第一个问题是ChatGPT 4，它没完没了地详细说明，我不得不纠正它，总之，我会给你ChatGPT答案的开头，也就是列表开始之前的部分。
what are the main sdks libraries and ways developers utilize GPUs. Then it started spitting out a bunch of garbage. And I said, stop, stop, stop. And I said, don't give me a description, just list me 20. And then ChatGPT responded, sure, here is a list of 20 SDKs, libraries, and tools for GPU programming. And then it goes one through 20. So the question is, how many can Bryce get? And I will give you a hint. The first one is extremely obvious. It might be so obvious that you might not guess it. But it's like the most obvious one when you ask, how do you target a GPU? I'm going to go with OpenGL. All right. So actually, wait, wait, wait. Let me get a little notepad out so your first answer was
主要的SDK、库以及开发者利用GPU的方式有哪些。然后它开始吐出一堆垃圾。我说，停，停，停。我说，别给我描述，直接给我列出20个。然后ChatGPT回答说，当然，这里有一个GPU编程的SDK、库和工具列表。然后它从1列到20。所以问题是，布莱斯能答对多少？我会给你一个提示。第一个非常明显。它可能太明显了，以至于你可能猜不到。但当你问，你如何定位GPU时，它是最明显的一个。我要选OpenGL。好的。所以其实，等等，等等。让我拿个小笔记本出来，所以你的第一个答案是
open gl that is number five answer on the board so you're one for one yeah what was your second one cuda cuda is the number one answer on the board so you're two for two vulcan vulcan is the number three answer on the board you're're three for three. You're crushing. So you're definitely. Did I say OpenCL? OpenCL is number two on the board. Four for four. Not a single miss yet.
OpenGL，那是板上的第五个答案，所以你答对了一个。是的，你的第二个是什么？CUDA，CUDA是板上的第一个答案，所以你答对了两个。Vulkan，Vulkan是板上的第三个答案，你答对了三个。你太强了。所以你绝对。我说过OpenCL了吗？OpenCL是板上的第二个答案。四对四。目前还没有一个错的。
So I've got number one, number two, number three. And number five. And number five. Which one was number five? So the order was CUDA, OpenCL, Vulcan, and then we skipped number four and then OpenGL. Gosh, I don't know what could be number four. Well, see, so the way that you program GPUs on, this is not my answer, but I'm going to explain why I'm not going to give it as an answer. I'm not going to say Metal, which is the the api for programming gpus on
所以我有了第一个、第二个、第三个。还有第五个。第五个是哪个？所以顺序是CUDA、OpenCL、Vulkan，然后我们跳过了第四个，然后是OpenGL。天哪，我不知道第四个可能是什么。好吧，你看，你编程GPU的方式，这不是我的答案，但我会解释为什么我不把它作为答案。我不会说Metal，它是用于在
apple's platform the reason i'm not gonna say it is because metal is newer um and so i think it's gonna appear like later on the list um oh uh wait hang on direct x direct number four is direct x crushing it so not not a single miss yet, folks. And I was going to say, well, go till you get like three or five misses. But at this rate, you know, you're going to run out of things to guess because you're crushing it so much. Yeah. And I think I'm going to be generous. Metal is number 18 on the list.
苹果平台上编程GPU的API。我不说它的原因是因为Metal比较新，所以我认为它会出现在列表的后面。哦，等等，稍等，DirectX，第四个是DirectX。太强了，伙计们，目前还没有一个错的。我本来想说，答到你错三到五次为止。但照这个速度，你知道，你会没东西可猜的，因为你太强了。是的。而且我觉得我会大方一点。Metal在列表上排第18位。
And that's because ChatGPT4, I think, got updated to like 2023 June, and it also has access. I see you typing, buddy. I see you typing. No, no. It's Ramona's calling me. Hang on. Pause. And, you know, the thing about that is—
那是因为ChatGPT 4，我想它更新到了2023年6月左右，而且它也有访问权限。我看到你在打字，伙计。我看到你在打字。不，不。是拉莫娜在给我打电话。稍等。暂停。而且，你知道，关于那件事——
Hands above your head. Hands above your head. The thing about that is that she knew that I was recording. You'd think that as time goes on, like the professional quality of this would like just steadily increase, but it seems like the opposite. That one was not my fault. I can't ignore a phone call from the girlfriend because it could be something urgent. And I would assume that if she was making a phone, if she was calling me on the phone
双手举过头顶。双手举过头顶。关于那件事是，她知道我在录音。你可能会认为随着时间的推移，这种专业质量会稳步提高，但看起来恰恰相反。那次不是我的错。我不能忽视女朋友的电话，因为可能有急事。而且我会假设，如果她在打电话，如果她在电话里给我打电话
while she knew I was recording the podcast, that it was something like something like oh i get hit by a bus or something like that not oh i can't find the petco order that i'm supposed to pick up all right so to recap bryce has got his hands above his head now he's gone five for five technically six for six because we're giving him metal which is number 18 on the list and not a not a single miss yet and we still got 14 to guess. Well, I'm going to say Thrust. Thrust is not on the list. Your first miss. That is the parallel algorithms library that we have talked about
当她知道我在录播客时，那一定是像……像……哦，我被公交车撞了之类的事情，而不是哦，我找不到我要去取的Petco订单。好了，总结一下，布莱斯现在双手举过头顶，他答对了五次，技术上是六次，因为我们给了他Metal，它是列表上的第18位，目前还没有一个错的，我们还有14个要猜。好吧，我要说Thrust。Thrust不在列表上。你的第一次失误。那是我们在这个播客上不时谈论的
from time to time on this podcast. How about HLSL? HLSL. That is not on the list. Yeah, that's like a... It's the high-level shader language. I think that's like a it's the high level shader language um i think it's like a part of hands above your head hands above your head hang on i'm looking at no it's like a direct x thing um let's see you want a hint think about uh libraries because remember chat gpt
并行算法库。HLSL怎么样？HLSL。那不在列表上。是的，那就像一个……它是高级着色器语言。我想那就像一个……它是高级着色器语言，嗯，我想它就像一个……双手举过头顶，双手举过头顶，稍等，我在看，不，它就像一个DirectX的东西，嗯，让我们看看，你想要个提示吗？想想……库，因为记住ChatGPT
responded sure here is a list of 20 sdks libraries and tools and a couple of these were actually on the diagram that I showed you, if you recall. The diagram? What did you show me a diagram? Remember a week ago, I ended up showing you the stuff I was working on and then mentioned that I was having a conversation. And my question was, you know, what's the most... Pie torch. Pie torch is number 12 on the list. What is that?
回答说，当然，这里有一个20个SDK、库和工具的列表，其中几个实际上就在我给你看的图表上，如果你还记得的话。图表？你给我看了图表吗？记得一周前，我最终给你看了我正在做的事情，然后提到我正在进行对话。我的问题是，你知道，最……PyTorch。PyTorch是列表上的第12位。那是什么？
So now seven for nine. If Pie Torch is on the list, that means that... Numba? What? Numba? Numba is a great guess. I was surprised to not see Numba on this list.
所以现在是九分之七。如果PyTorch在列表上，那意味着……Numba？什么？Numba？Numba是个很好的猜测。我很惊讶在这个列表上没看到Numba。
But Numba is not on this list. Are you suggesting that Torch is on the list because Pie Torch is on the list? That is not what I was suggesting. Okay. Then continue with your interpretation. There is a massive competitor that used to be more popular than PyTorch. Oh, TensorFlow?
但Numba不在这个列表上。你是说Torch在列表上是因为PyTorch在列表上吗？那不是我的意思。好吧。那你继续你的解释。有一个曾经比PyTorch更受欢迎的巨大竞争对手。哦，TensorFlow？
That is correct. Number 11 on the list. Sorry to everyone I know who works on TensorFlow. So I still haven't gotten 6, 7, 8? You haven't gotten six through ten. At this point, you've got the top five, number 11, TensorFlow, number 12, PyTorch, and number 18, Metal, which is a grand total of eight. You've had three misses, so we'll give you two more misses. And definitely, oh, here's another hint.
那是正确的。列表上的第11位。对所有我知道在TensorFlow工作的人表示抱歉。所以我还是没答对6、7、8？你还没答对6到10。此时，你已经有了前五名，第11名TensorFlow，第12名PyTorch，和第18名Metal，总共八个。你已经有三次失误了，所以我们再给你两次失误的机会。而且绝对，哦，这里还有个提示。
So number eight, number nine, number 17 are all by NVIDIA. Are all by NVIDIA. Are all by NVIDIA. And actually number 20 as well, although they don't have the name of NVIDIA in the title of it. And actually number 9 doesn't as well. But anyways, number 9, number 10, number 17, and number 20. Is one of them something that you've worked on? One of them is something that I've worked on, yes. Rapids?
所以第8名、第9名、第17名都是NVIDIA的。都是NVIDIA的。都是NVIDIA的。实际上第20名也是，尽管它们的标题里没有NVIDIA的名字。实际上第9名也没有。但总之，第9名、第10名、第17名和第20名。其中一个是你有参与过的吗？其中一个是我有参与过的，是的。Rapids？
Rapids comes in at number 20. And actually, it's interesting. It says Rapids. That's surprising. Yeah, it says Rapid AI. And then in parentheses, formerly known as Rapids, a suite of libraries for data science on GPUs. I checked. I don't think it's Rapid AI.
Rapids排在第20位。而且实际上，这很有趣。它写的是Rapids。这很令人惊讶。是的，它写的是Rapid AI。然后在括号里写着，前身为Rapids，一套用于GPU数据科学的库。我查过了。我不认为它是Rapid AI。
I'm pretty sure it's called the URL is rapids.ai. And at least the marketing stuff on the main landing page still says Rapids. So Rapids, which is the GPU accelerated version of the popular Python library pandas. So now we've got nine. We're nine for 12. What else do we have that programs GPUs? So number eight, number nine, and number 17 are all NVIDIA made. I know two of them are...
我很确定它叫URL是rapids.ai。而且至少主页上的营销内容仍然写着Rapids。所以Rapids，它是流行的Python库pandas的GPU加速版本。所以现在我们有九个了。我们12个里答对了9个。我们还有什么编程GPU的东西？所以第8名、第9名和第17名都是NVIDIA制造的。我知道其中两个是……
Are they computer graphics? One of them is compute. Two of them is compute. Two of them is compute. And I think the third one leans more towards graphics. Yeah. Oh, God. What's the name of the RTX thingy? The library.
它们是计算机图形吗？其中一个是计算。两个是计算。两个是计算。而且我认为第三个更偏向图形。是的。哦，天哪。RTX那个东西叫什么名字？那个库。
But I don't think it could be that one. What's the name of the RTX library? I don't know. And I don't think it's one of these three so dlss it is not dlss and that's not the rtx thing is it that's the uh no that's that's the super sampling thing that like upskills your 1080p to 4k yeah one wrong guess left hang on okay okay i'm gonna take another is unreal engine on? Unreal is not on there. So in total, you got... That's pretty good, man.
但我认为不可能是那个。RTX库叫什么名字？我不知道。而且我不认为它是这三个中的一个，所以DLSS，不是DLSS，那不是RTX的东西，对吧？那是……不，那是那个超采样技术，把你的1080p提升到4k的那个。是的，还剩一个错误猜测机会。稍等，好的，好的，我要再猜一个，Unreal Engine在上面吗？Unreal不在上面。所以总共，你……那很不错，伙计。
I thought you'd get roughly five because that's what I thought I would get just because some of these are off in the weeds. But you got nine correct, five incorrect guesses. But Numba, Thrust, I think are fantastic guesses. I actually don't know much about HLSL. But here, let's go through. So to recap what Bryce got,
我以为你大概能答对五个，因为那是我觉得我会答对的，只是因为其中一些太偏门了。但你答对了九个，答错了五个。但Numba、Thrust，我觉得是非常棒的猜测。我其实对HLSL了解不多。但在这里，让我们过一遍。所以总结一下布莱斯答对的，
number one, CUDA, number two, OpenCL, number three, Vulkan, number four, DirectX, number five, OpenGL, number 11, TensorFlow, number 12, PyTorch, number 18, Apple Metal,
第一名CUDA，第二名OpenCL，第三名Vulkan，第四名DirectX，第五名OpenGL，第11名TensorFlow，第12名PyTorch，第18名Apple Metal，
and number 20, Rapids. We'll go through now the ones that you missed. And this is going to be entertaining. Number six was WebGL. I definitely wouldn't have gotten that just because it's not top of mind. I swear to God, if Cub's on this list, I'm going to be entertaining. Number six was WebGL. I definitely wouldn't have gotten that just because it's not top of mind. I swear to God, if Cub's on this list, I'm going to be pissed. Cub is not on the list.
和第20名Rapids。我们现在过一遍你错过的那些。这会很有趣。第六名是WebGL。我肯定答不对，因为它不是首选。我发誓，如果Cub在这个列表上，我会……这会很有趣。第六名是WebGL。我肯定答不对，因为它不是首选。我发誓，如果Cub在这个列表上，我会很火大。Cub不在列表上。
Cub's the, you know, sibling library to Thrust. Number seven from our competitor. Can you guess based on that? AMD. Sickle? Nope. Hip? Nope.
Cub是，你知道，Thrust的兄弟库。来自我们竞争对手的第七名。你能根据那个猜出来吗？AMD。SYCL？不是。HIP？不是。
I actually only learned about this. One API? Like a few months ago one api is number 19 but that's by intel not amd kuda's number one and one api is number 19 that's the world i want to live in sorry to all of our listeners who work on intel but uh number seven though is amd's what's their version of kuda do you know rockham yeah rockham okay but it's it's called hip now but i fun fact i was actually at the launch event for rockham wait rockham is called hip since when the hip would be the more proper thing to call it rockham's like the name for the
我其实只了解这个。oneAPI？像几个月前，oneAPI是第19名，但那是英特尔的，不是AMD的。CUDA是第一名，oneAPI是第19名，那是我想要生活的世界。对所有在英特尔工作的听众表示抱歉，但……第七名是AMD的，你知道他们版本的CUDA是什么吗？ROCm。是的，ROCm。好的，但它现在叫HIP，但我有个有趣的事实，我实际上在ROCm的发布会上。等等，ROCm叫HIP，从什么时候开始的？HIP会是更合适的称呼。ROCm就像是那个
like overarching suite back but when i worked at berkeley lab um i think his name was greg he was like the product manager for um uh rockham And I got invited to go down to Santa Clara. This is when I lived in Berkeley. He invited me to come down to Santa Clara for their launch of Rock'Em. And he was really into like rock music. And I don't recall if he played a guitar there, but there was some like rock, like there was definitely like a rock music theme to the launch event. But yeah, I was there at the launch event for Rock'Em. And that was where? What city?
总括套件的名字，但当我在伯克利实验室工作时，嗯，我想他叫格雷格，他是ROCm的产品经理。我被邀请去圣克拉拉。那是我住在伯克利的时候。他邀请我下到圣克拉拉参加他们的ROCm发布会。他非常喜欢摇滚乐。我不记得他在那里是否弹了吉他，但确实有一些摇滚，发布会上绝对有摇滚音乐的主题。但是的，我在ROCm的发布会上。那是在哪里？哪个城市？
It was in San Jose, I think. Okay. Yeah. Interesting. So wait. Okay, so – What is – just to pause on this, you know, has you know i think rockham is the name for the overall software stack but hip is specifically their like cuda like clone i see i see yeah so the
我想是在圣何塞。好的。是的。有趣。所以等等。好的，所以——什么是——只是暂停一下，你知道，有……你知道，我认为ROCm是整个软件栈的名字，但HIP是他们专门的类似CUDA的克隆。我明白了，我明白了。是的，所以
wikipedia says rockham is an amd software stack for gpu programming and it spans several different domains blah blah blah but then it says it offers several programming models and then proceeds to list yeah three or four of them which is hip like hip is yeah yeah i i'm sorry i was confused really hip is one but like i think when rockham launched um it was supposed to be like their like cuda like cuda for their platform and i think later the hip branding got introduced uh interesting so i think that that's why that's why i thought that that rockham had been renamed to hit because i think originally and what rock was was supposed to be like their kuda but i i could be i could be wrong about that anyways but yeah rockham is like the overall like like um uh plat like in the same sense that like like kuda is like the overall platform but like kuda c++ is one way to program that like rockham is the overall platform and hip is their kuda c++
维基百科说ROCm是AMD用于GPU编程的软件栈，它跨越了几个不同的领域，等等等等，但它接着说它提供了几种编程模型，然后继续列出，是的，三四个，其中一个是HIP，就像HIP是……是的，是的，我，我，我很抱歉，我搞混了。真的，HIP是一个，但我认为当ROCm发布时，嗯，它应该是他们平台的类似CUDA的东西，我想后来引入了HIP品牌。有趣。所以我想这就是为什么，这就是为什么我以为ROCm被重命名为HIP，因为我想最初ROCm应该是他们的CUDA，但我可能，我可能搞错了。总之，但是的，ROCm就像是整体的，就像……嗯，平台，就像CUDA是整体平台一样，但CUDA C++是编程该平台的一种方式，就像ROCm是整体平台，而HIP是他们的CUDA C++
equivalent anyways give me the rest of the list all right so that was number seven number eight and number nine are both from nvidia it starts with ku and ends in three letters under under underpins both pie torch and tensorflow ku dnn ku dN is correct, yes. I expected you to get that one as well. Number nine, a little bit more esoteric, but we've been getting emails, I think every week,
等价物。总之，把剩下的列表给我。好的，所以那是第七名。第八名和第九名都是NVIDIA的。它以KU开头，以三个字母结尾，支撑着PyTorch和TensorFlow。cuDNN。cuDNN是正确的，是的。我以为你也会答对那个。第九名，稍微有点深奥，但我们一直在收到邮件，我想每周都有，
and it's been called Insert Tuesday. Have you been reading your NVIDIA emails closely enough? And that being said, we get literally like thousands of emails, and that's even after like filtering them. Yeah. TensorRT. Yeah, NVIDIA. Oh, TensorRT. Although actually... Yes, I forgot about that. thousands of emails and that's even after like filtering them yeah tensor rt yeah nvidia oh
它被称为“插入周二”。你有仔细阅读你的NVIDIA邮件吗？话虽如此，我们确实收到了成千上万封邮件，那还是在过滤之后。是的。TensorRT。是的，NVIDIA。哦，TensorRT。虽然实际上……是的，我忘了那个。成千上万封邮件，那还是在过滤之后。是的，TensorRT。是的，NVIDIA。哦，
tensor rt although actually yes i forgot about that i forgot about tensor rt yeah now that i'm actually thinking about this though uh is it is it tensor rt tuesdays now that i think about it i don't think it's tensor rt tuesdays no it is tensor rt tuesdays hopefully this isn't like proprietary stuff it's all right to mention that. I'm in public, right? The name of a NVIDIA internal email. I mean, I think this whole podcast episode is sketchy because we're talking about competitors' SDKs. And I seem to recall earlier I made a crude joke at Intel's expense.
TensorRT。虽然实际上，是的，我忘了那个。我忘了TensorRT。是的，现在我真的在想这个，嗯，是……是TensorRT周二吗？现在我想起来了，我不认为它是TensorRT周二。不，它是TensorRT周二。希望这不是什么专有内容，提到它没关系吧。我在公共场合，对吧？NVIDIA内部邮件的名字。我是说，我觉得整个播客节目都很可疑，因为我们在谈论竞争对手的SDK。而且我似乎记得早些时候我开了个关于英特尔的粗俗玩笑。
But you know what? Hey. It is what it is. This is not the opinions of NVIDIA. It's the opinions of us. And this is just what ChatGPT lists. We didn't put them number seven. This is what ChatGPT lists.
但你知道吗？嘿。事实就是这样。这不是NVIDIA的观点。这是我们的观点。这只是ChatGPT列出的。我们没有把它们排在第七位。这是ChatGPT列出的。
Buddy, okay, but buddy, but what trained ChatGPT? The compute that trains. NVIDIA GPUs. Yeah, but that doesn't affect the answers i'm telling you that that large language model it almost certainly knows how it was trained right i don't think so i'm sure that i'm sure that in the uh the input data there's a lot of information that says large that the that open ai uses nvidia gpus and so of course you ask it you're asking that's basically asking
伙计，好吧，但是伙计，但是什么训练了ChatGPT？训练用的计算资源。NVIDIA GPU。是的，但这并不影响答案。我告诉你，那个大语言模型几乎肯定知道它是如何被训练出来的。对吧？我不这么认为。我确信，我确信在输入数据中，有很多信息说大……OpenAI使用NVIDIA GPU，所以当然你问它，你问的是，这基本上是在问
it like how were you born it is funny actually because number 13 on the list is open ai gpt oh that's interesting that's interesting which uh i don't know i didn't to call open ai gpt like an sdk i guess maybe because there are SDKs attached to like. Yeah. I mean, like I've used the OpenAI API. So, yeah. Not shocked by that one. Continuing down the list.
它，就像你出生时是什么样。这其实很有趣，因为列表上的第13名是OpenAI GPT。哦，那很有趣，那很有趣。我不知道，我没想到把OpenAI GPT称为SDK，我想也许是因为有SDK连接到……是的。我是说，就像我用过OpenAI API。所以，是的。对那个不感到震惊。继续往下看列表。
Number 10 is PyCuda, which I am actually not familiar with. Number 11, we already covered. So we'll skip to number four. Oh, yeah. I think PyCuda is not actually a thing that we officially support i think pykuda is like the python kuda um interface thingy okay number 14 microsoft cntk the cognitive toolkit never heard of it number 15 theano with gpu support which I'm surprised that's up there because from what I know, like Cafe and Theano are like pretty old technologies. But hey, probably there's a lot of stuff out there.
第10名是PyCUDA，我其实不熟悉。第11名，我们已经讲过了。所以我们跳到第4名。哦，是的。我想PyCUDA其实不是我们官方支持的东西，我想PyCUDA就像是Python CUDA接口之类的东西。好的，第14名微软CNTK，认知工具包，没听说过。第15名带有GPU支持的Theano，我很惊讶它排在上面，因为据我所知，像Caffe和Theano都是相当古老的技术。但嘿，可能外面有很多东西。
Number 16, AMD Fire Pro. Never heard of it. Have you heard of it? A long, long time ago. And number 17 is NVIDIA PhysX, which i assume is a physics sdk or library yeah but okay so amd fire pro i don't think it was their name of like their software i think it was just the name for their like their brand of graphics cards it It was like for the... It says in parentheses next to AMD Fire Pro that it was an STK for AMD GPUs.
第16名AMD FirePro。没听说过。你听说过吗？很久很久以前。第17名是NVIDIA PhysX，我假设它是一个物理SDK或库。是的，但好吧，所以AMD FirePro，我不认为那是他们软件的名字，我认为那只是他们显卡品牌的名称。它就像是……在AMD FirePro旁边的括号里写着它是一个用于AMD GPU的SDK。
Maybe it was. But I think it was, I'm pretty sure it was old. I'm pretty sure it was like the 2000s. Yeah, well, I'm not surprised. I mean, Theano, let's check in on Theano. Ooh, that's not what I meant to do. Just closed all my tabs. Nice, closing all your tabs well control shift t baby theano is a python library for optimizing compiler and manipulating it opens up your most recently
也许是吧。但我认为它是，我很确定它是旧的。我很确定它就像2000年代的。是的，好吧，我不惊讶。我是说，Theano，让我们看看Theano。噢，我不是那个意思。刚刚关闭了我所有的标签页。不错，关闭你所有的标签页。好吧，Ctrl+Shift+T，宝贝。Theano是一个用于优化编译器和操作的Python库，它打开你最近
closed tabs and if you close the whole window it'll reopen everything so whenever your computer restarts i mean it always asks if you want to restore but if you uh need to and you like accidentally clicked no to that you can just go control shift t a bunch of times i mean yeah theano came out in 2007 yeah so yeah it's been a while for a while been a while been around for a while anyway so i guess to wrap up this little i mean first of all you you did fantastic. Definitely better than I would have done. Hey, you know what? It's great to have a quiz for once
关闭的标签页，如果你关闭了整个窗口，它会重新打开所有东西。所以无论什么时候你的电脑重启，我是说它总是问你是否想恢复，但如果你需要，而且你不小心点了否，你可以直接按几次Ctrl+Shift+T。我是说，是的，Theano是2007年出来的。是的，所以是的，已经有一段时间了，有一段时间了，存在有一段时间了。总之，我想总结一下这个小……我是说，首先，你做得太棒了。绝对比我会做的要好。嘿，你知道吗？能有一次测验
that I did good on. Babe, I did good on the quiz. And what's even more important is that you crushed top five, you know, right off the bat without even getting a single one wrong, which is pretty impressive. And
我做得很好。宝贝，我在测验中做得很好。而且更重要的是，你直接答对了前五名，你知道，甚至没有答错一个，这非常令人印象深刻。而且
I guess, you know, to put a little bow on this little 30-minute episode is the question that, you know, Bryce and I were talking about a week ago off pod was, you know, what is the main way that developers target GPUs? Like, what path are they taking? Is it, is the number one, you know, and that includes things like PyTorch and TensorFlow, where even though you know, potentially, it's not like you're doing, quote unquote, GPU programming, you're just doing, you know, machine learning stuff that happens to, at the end of the day, target accelerated compute, which could be in the form of a GPU.
我想，你知道，给这个30分钟的节目打个结，布莱斯和我一周前在播客外谈论的问题是，你知道，开发者定位GPU的主要方式是什么？就像，他们走的是什么路径？是，是第一名，你知道，这包括像PyTorch和TensorFlow这样的东西，虽然你知道，潜在地，这不像你在做所谓的GPU编程，你只是在做，你知道，机器学习的东西，碰巧在一天结束时，定位加速计算，这可能是以GPU的形式。
Like, is that where most of, like, if you were to create a pie chart of developers that target GPU compute, and for our concern, it's, you know, mostly, like I said before, NVIDIA GPUs, what does that pie chart look like? And that's something that I don't really have the answer to. I don't know. I haven't seen any GTC talks or keynotes that talk about that because I think most investors and people that care about NVIDIA, it's not something they care about. But as like a developer and someone that works on libraries, it's something that I've been thinking about recently. Anyways, thoughts, comments? I know your initial response was, yeah, I haven't heard of a slide that shows that data. Well, yeah. I feel like maybe this is just my corporate experience, but I feel like so often data like this that would totally help us make better decisions.
就像，如果我们要创建一个定位GPU计算的开发者的饼图，对于我们的关注点，它是，你知道，像我之前说的，主要是NVIDIA GPU，那个饼图看起来是什么样的？这是我真的没有答案的东西。我不知道。我没看过任何GTC演讲或主题演讲谈论这个，因为我认为大多数投资者和关心NVIDIA的人，这不是他们关心的东西。但作为一个开发者和从事库工作的人，这是我最近一直在思考的事情。总之，想法，评论？我知道你最初的反应是，是的，我没听说过显示该数据的幻灯片。好吧，是的。我觉得也许这只是我的企业经验，但我感觉经常有这样的数据，如果能完全帮助我们做出更好的决策。
I feel like there are so many software organizations that don't really know the answers to these things. And then because you don't actually have data on how your thing is used, you just like you make decisions based on how people not even think things are used, but how people feel things are used. And I make the distinction because thinking is like a logical process, whereas feeling is an emotional process. And that's how I think we often approach this question. You know, I'm sure that there is some data that somebody has, but the fact that it's not something that like is in front of me is like a bad sign right like that's something that that I should be that like every every like senior engineer at the company should have a should have a good sense of that right but it's also when you have a product in nested kids
我觉得有太多的软件组织根本不知道这些事情的答案。然后因为你实际上没有关于你的东西是如何使用的数据，你只是，你根据人们甚至不认为事情是如何使用的，而是人们感觉事情是如何使用的来做决定。我做出这个区分是因为思考是一个逻辑过程，而感觉是一个情感过程。这就是我认为我们经常处理这个问题的方式。你知道，我确信有人有数据，但它不是那种摆在我面前的东西，这是一个坏迹象，对吧？那是那种，那是我应该……那就像公司里的每一位高级工程师都应该对那个有很好的感觉，对吧？但这也是当你有一个像我们这样被广泛使用的产品和SDK时
as widely used as ours it is difficult to truly survey and understand all of your users, you know? And also, like, how do you assign importance? Is it by the number of developers that work on the thing? Is it by the amount of revenue that they generate? Is it by, like, you know, is it by the amount of code that's written by a particular domain? Or is it by how often that code is run? I think it's very difficult to actually quantify how your software is used.
要真正调查和了解你所有的用户是很困难的，你知道吗？而且，像，你如何分配重要性？是按从事该工作的开发者数量吗？是按他们产生的收入吗？是按，你知道，是按特定领域编写的代码量吗？还是按代码运行的频率？我认为量化你的软件是如何被使用的非常困难。
Maybe there's one 10-line program somewhere that's run on every computer in the world. And that's how your software is most frequently used um versus all the like all the other like thousands of lines that are of code that are written that use your library like are are barely used it's just that one place where it's used a bunch of times i mean i completely agree that this is an extremely hard thing to measure i i was i just while you were chatting, I googled, you know, CUDA developer survey, because I'm pretty sure that doesn't exist. And sure enough, it does not. We have, I think, some byproduct surveys, like I think the fourth
也许某个地方有一个10行的程序在世界上每台电脑上运行。而这就是你的软件最常被使用的方式，嗯，相对于所有那些成千上万行编写的使用你的库的代码，它们几乎没被使用，只是在那个被多次使用的地方。我是说，我完全同意这是一个极其难以衡量的事情。我，我只是在你聊天的时候，我谷歌了，你知道，CUDA开发者调查，因为我确信那不存在。果然，它确实不存在。我们有，我想，一些副产品调查，比如我想第四
or third top thing was a CU DNN stakeholder survey. But I mean, if there's a C++, what do they call it? Community survey. There's a couple of them, right? One's done by the ISO Foundation. One's done by JetBrains. I think we should try to collect some of that data. I mean, it's kind of sad that like-
或第三个最重要的事情是cuDNN利益相关者调查。但我是说，如果有一个C++，他们叫什么？社区调查。有几个，对吧？一个是ISO基金会做的。一个是JetBrains做的。我认为我们应该尝试收集一些数据。我是说，这有点可悲，像——
I've been saying that for years. I've been trying to put together a CUDA survey for years. Yeah, I mean, why can't we? I think we should commit. I mean, you know. Lazy list. What? Laziness mostly.
我多年来一直这么说。我多年来一直试图整理一份CUDA调查。是的，我是说，为什么我们不能？我认为我们应该承诺。我是说，你知道。懒惰列表。什么？主要是懒惰。
Yeah, I mean, we can make it happen if we wanted to. And I think actually like the, you know. Honestly, if you wanted to ask me the reason why I've never like completed plans to put that through. And like I've written it on my to-do list like four or five times over the six years I've been here on NVIDIA. Um, it's just, it's not as exciting a thing to do. It's important, but it's not as exciting or cool. And also it, it always seems like it's a lot of work. There's a lot of like privacy and concerns and whatnot like that. So see, if we were going to do this, I would want to do it correctly. And the way that I would want to do it,
是的，我是说，如果我们想的话，我们可以实现它。而且我认为实际上，你知道。老实说，如果你想问我为什么我从来没有像完成计划那样去执行它。而且就像我在NVIDIA工作这六年里，我把它写在我的待办事项清单上四五次了。嗯，它只是，它不是一件那么令人兴奋的事情。它很重要，但它不像其他事情那样令人兴奋或酷。而且它，它总是看起来像有很多工作。有很多像隐私和担忧之类的东西。所以看，如果我们要做这个，我想正确地做。而我想做的方式，
this brings up something that's actually been on a recent episode unless Connor's gotten rid of it. The JetBrains developer ecosystem survey. You know what JetBrains did? One, they didn't try to go and run the survey themselves. They went and hired people
这引出了最近一期节目中实际上提到过的事情，除非康纳把它删了。JetBrains开发者生态系统调查。你知道JetBrains做了什么吗？第一，他们没有试图自己去运行调查。他们去雇佣了人
who are professional survey runners and they're like, tell us how to do this. And two, they do the survey and. They went and hired people who are professional survey runners and they're like, tell us how to do this. And two, they do the survey and then they publish the results and they not only publish the results, they don't publish all the data, but they publish the results
他们是专业的调查人员，他们就像，告诉我们怎么做。第二，他们做调查，而且。他们去雇佣了人，他们是专业的调查人员，他们就像，告诉我们怎么做。第二，他们做调查，然后他们发布结果，他们不仅发布结果，他们不发布所有数据，但他们发布结果
and they publish a description of those statistical methods and they 100% do this the correct way. So if I was going to do this sort of survey at NVIDIA, I would not get together a group of people to come up with a set of questions and make a Google Drive form. I would want to get a pile of money and go to some company who are professionals in doing surveys and be like, you go figure this out. Here's my requirements.
而且他们发布了这些统计方法的描述，他们100%以正确的方式做这件事。所以如果我要在NVIDIA做这种调查，我不会召集一群人来想出一套问题并制作一个Google Drive表格。我会想拿一大笔钱，去找一些专业的调查公司，然后说，你去搞定这个。这是我的要求。
You go figure this out for me. I mean, I completely agree. And I think whatever piles of money it costs to make that happen probably is worth it. I mean, like, it's sad. You Google CUDA developer survey and the 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7th result is CUDA versus RockM, the ongoing battle for GPU computing, dot, dot, dot. And it's a Medium article by, I don't know who this is, doesn't actually say. We'll leave it. I mean, I haven't even read it. I just glanced at it. But the point is, is like, we should be collecting this kind of like we have a GTC, you know, we have more than one of them. But like the main one happens, whatever, March, April, how hard would it be? Like if we contact one of these surveying companies, a couple months out, say here's our criteria. And we want to like, you know, provide this for every single person that either virtually attends or in personperson attends has the ability. Plus, we'll also, like, put the link online for anyone that just wants to go and fill it out.
你去为我搞定这个。我是说，我完全同意。而且我认为无论花多少钱来实现这一点，可能都是值得的。我是说，这很可悲。你谷歌CUDA开发者调查，第1、2、3、4、5、6、7个结果是CUDA与ROCm，GPU计算的持续战斗，点，点，点。这是一篇Medium文章，作者是，我不知道这是谁，实际上没写。我们不管它。我是说，我甚至没读过。我只是扫了一眼。但重点是，就像，我们应该收集这种，就像我们有GTC，你知道，我们不止一个。但像主要的那个发生，不管怎样，三月，四月，这有多难？就像如果我们联系这些调查公司中的一家，提前几个月，说这是我们的标准。我们想要，你知道，为每一个虚拟参加或亲自参加的人提供这个，他们有能力。另外，我们也会，像，把链接放在网上，给任何只想去填写的人。
And I think we would get thousands of responses. Like, supposedly, there are, like, four to five million registered CUDA developers or something like that in the world. Like, it'd be pretty easy to get, I think, several thousand, you know. Anyways, we'll put it on our list, folks. I mean, look, and if it's too expensive, we can always just, you know, take that out of your pay, right? I mean, not my pay. Take it out of your pay. Anyways, that'll wrap.
而且我认为我们会得到成千上万的回复。就像，据称，世界上有四到五百万注册的CUDA开发者之类的。就像，我认为得到几千个回复会很容易，你知道。总之，我们会把它列入我们的清单，伙计们。我是说，看，如果太贵了，我们总是可以，你知道，从你的工资里扣除，对吧？我是说，不是我的工资。从你的工资里扣除。总之，就这样吧。
What are we on? ADSP episode 166. Be sure to check the show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSPthep dot com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a GitHub discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quality. That is the tagline of our podcast. That's not the tagline.
我们现在在做什么？ADSP第166期。一定要查看你的播客应用中的节目说明，或者在ADSPthep点com查看我们今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个GitHub讨论的链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。低质量，高质量。那是我们播客的标语。那不是标语。
Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的标语是带有信息点缀的混乱。这一期节目还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。